[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Leah and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's Di into today's episode and embark
on a great journey
together our high school years are a
treasur test of memories but they can
also be a time of profound challenges
for Young Hearts from The Towering
expectations of academics to the
intricate dance of social dynamics
adolescents often find themselves
grappling with an emotional burden that
demands our
attention today our mission is to shine
a beacon of light on this Paramount
issue exploring ways in which we can
create a nurturing environment for our
teenagers high school it's a time of
metamorphosis isn't it but we the glitz
of prom nights and the Roar of football
games lie unique mental health struggles
for our
teens from The Towering expectations of
academic Perfection to the delicate
choreography of social interactions
young ones carry a heavy backpack of
stressors that can cast a shadow on
their mental well-being
today we embark on an expedition to
uncover the layers of this intricut
puzzle providing insights into how we
can craft an environment that truly
supports the Adolescence in our
life let's build our understanding on
the Bedrock of the Paramount importance
of mental health in the grand Mosaic of
overall
well-being each teenager's journey is a
canvas painted with unique Strokes what
brings peace to one heart may not
resonate with another nevertheless there
are common hurdles that many teens face
at the front line of this battlefield we
encounter academic pressure the
ceaseless Marathon to excel academically
meet deadlines and attain perfect in
exams can be a formidable adversary it
is incub upon parents Educators and our
broader Community to promote a
well-rounded approach to education
balancing the skills between academic
achievements and self-care for the sake
of mental
well-being the intricate choreography of
social dynamics is another layer in the
Symphony of Dean mental health
adolescence a time of self-discovery and
the weaving of social connections can
also be a period marked by the duet of
peer pressured and bullying often
followed by The Haunting solo of
isolation the alchemi lies in nurturing
open dialogue weaving empathy into the
fabric of
relationships creating safe havens for
our teens to express themselves so they
never feel alone on their
Journey the technological landscape adds
another dimension to this intricate
tapestry while technology has enriched
our lives in countless ways an overdose
of screen time and the Relentless demand
to maintain an impeccably curated online
Persona can sow the seeds of inadequacy
and low
self-esteem encouraging balanced
technology habits and fostering a
harmonious blend between the virtual and
physical worlds can be a balm for these
challenges so how can we be the wind
beneath the wings of our high schoolers
as they navigate these
challenges first and foremost let's
Champion open conversations about Mental
Health let's tear down the barriers of
stigma that have plagued this vital
topic for far too long and create safe
spaces where teens can share their Tales
of Triumph and
tribulation then we have the art of
self-care regular exercise a balanced
diet and the elixir of sufficient sleep
these may seem like simple act but they
are the keystones of well-being
encouraging our teens to indulge in
activities they are passionate about be
it a hobby a sport or a creative Outlet
can offer a sense of purpose and
fulfillment in their
lives lastly the knowledge of available
resources in
Paramount many schools offer counseling
services and have mental health
professionals on hun to provide guidance
parents teachers and friends can also
play pivotal roles by Rec recognizing
the subtle signs of distress and
becoming that empathetic ear or guiding
Beacon remember supporting Teen Mental
Health is communal effort by nurturing a
culture of care igniting open
conversations and ensuring accessibility
to resources we can become the pillars
teenagers lean on as they navigate the
Labyrinth of high school ultimately
eliminate the path to their overall
well-being thank you so much for joining
us on this episode of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take care and prior
prioritize your mental
[Music]
well-being